[Music]
Chucky's show with how Rudnick thanks
movie trailer voice guy welcome to the
first episode of the screen junkies show
our new weekly series where we'll
celebrate and/or crap on whatever's
happening in film and TV and why should
you care is we're the same people who
make those honest trailers you like
those you click on them a lot so just
relax for a few minutes and watch this
you guys flooded our servers demanding
an Avengers honest trailer first we
ignored you because the movies
untouchable its Teflon
but finally we relented as we began to
nitpick this film to death it begged the
question who doesn't like this movie in
this hard-hitting screen junkies expose
I posted an ad on Craigslist after
attending a delightful swingers party in
Orange County I posted another ad
seeking people who legitimately didn't
like the Avengers what I discovered was
horrifying
you saw the Avengers yes what do you
think of the film um I thought it sucks
I think I expected more I do like it
that much
I fell asleep halfway through it are you
narcoleptic now the movie which is
complete garbage I don't mean any
offence by this we're just trying to get
into your head are you an no
what I do like about the event is that
when Thor and his brother were fighting
yeah their brother they're not supposed
to be fighting you know what they're not
supposed to be mean to each other
one brother shouldn't use the power of
the tesseract to get the Chitauri army
to take over a planet where his
brother's girlfriend lives but
unfortunately those are the
circumstances we were dealt Ruby don't
you understand that mm-hmm
what'd you think of the actors and I
like Salome very much he's not an
Avenger might be thinking of the
Expendables
if you thought it was too long how would
you have made it shorter
I feel got a together and just like
took Loki out if hope got his
together
yeah the Hulk is flawed he's got this
rage issue he can't control imagine if
you were just constantly on the cusp of
getting your period
I don't like Subarus because they're
like they don't exist I like nonfiction
what's your favorite movie
baby knee heals Chu Allah - are you dead
inside
the hell's wrong with you you know
you're the only people in America that
dislike this movie I don't respect any
of you have do you really have to argue
with us just because we don't like the
adventures yeah because you guys are way
off base
this movie was a celebration of
Awesomeness all of these iconic
characters came together to kick ass we
don't like the movies so just do with it
you're grounded you're grounded no okay
listen young child you're rising I'm out
to be fair you guys I just call timeout
will you just give me one chance to let
you experience the Avengers
[Music]
come on guys this is awesome huh
it's pretty awesome you gotta admit this
move
after we dressed up we all went out to
Applebee's should we have gone to
Chili's who in the group did you hate
most I didn't like that little Beverly
Hills Chihuahua girl leave us a comment
let us know it's your show people I'm
just here to say what needs to be said
let's go to the comments section and
tell us what you want to see
investigated next too many boobs on Game
of Thrones
well Shia LeBouf ever go away whose
fault is this new Robocop suit kind of
sucks we'll kick down doors and Google
and a lot of stuff until we find an
answer we'll be uploading new screen
junkie shows every Wednesday and more
honest trailers every other Friday
because we know that's all you really
care about so get used to it people and
subscribe and create ghost accounts and
to have them subscribe too I'm Hal
Rudnick bye-bye the Avengers the
ultimate - our geek fantasy that blinds
all nerds from admitting any legitimate
criticism and put all of DC Comics on
suicide watch